真的是太難了
當我們一開始進入股市的時候
最常見的問題就是什麼
不知道哪一支股票可以賣
那這個時候呢
多數人就會開始聽信朋友
新聞
加入一些LINE群組
然後聽到裡面的一些資訊
投資什麼股票啊
老實和你講
我以前也是這個樣子
然後賠掉了很多辛苦的存款
而我現在是完全不會去聽明白的
而我今天用過來人的產動經驗和你分享
千萬別這麼做
這會讓你辛苦賺來的錢
直接賠進股市
大多時候
這些消息因為缺乏了全面的投資觀念
會造成我們的虧損
那怎麼辦
所以今天呢就要來幫助你建立
選擇強勢股票的背後邏輯
你就能跟投資高手一樣
擁有這樣子的投資思維
選擇強勢的股票來做投資
今天的影片重點呢
1.強勢股有什麼樣的特性
2.如何找出強勢股
這背後的邏輯又是什麼
聽完今天的內容
你就可以了解投資高手
為什麼總是可以選到那些大漲的股票
而你也可以做得到
嗨我是威德
這個頻道呢
主要会用日常的人坏来帮助你了解投资理财
自我成长的知识
你如果不想错过任何赚钱跟成长的知识
现在就帮我们按下订阅吧
因为你的支持是我们创作影片的动力
先来介绍强势股有什么样的特性
简单来说
当经济环境不好的时候
强势股比较不会下跌
我们在股票市场上会说抗跌
甚至呢它还会有缓缓上涨的状况
当经济环境变好的时候
强势股会涨得比一般股票多
非常多
举个生活中的例子在我们上学的时候会有放牛班对吧那班级里的学习气氛呢非常的懒散自然大部分的学生成绩就会比较差但是却有少数的一到两位表现特别出色
他的成绩呢总是在前三名
回到股票
刚刚懒散班级的气氛啊
比喻成市场经济氛围不好
而成绩表现优秀的少数学生呢
也就是强势股
所以强势股就算经济氛围不好
也具备抗跌的特性
有上涨的潜力
但要注意啊
强势股不会永远都是强势
会跟着市场的趋势不同
时间的不同
强势股也会有所不同
就像是每个时期都有属于那个时期的当红明星
像我78年次就是钱益逊啊
曹格啊
李盛杰啊
而现在年轻人可能就完全不认识他们
再来介绍如何选出强势股
先问你一个问题
当我们在高中的时候
假设今天要考第一次的段考
而今天有升学A
B
C班级
这三个班级的所有学生
谁比较能够有机会考到全校前三名呢
聪明的你可能会知道
每个班级的前三名都是非常优秀的学生
有很多的机会比较容易考到全校前三名
当今天考完第一次段考后
结果都是升学A班霸占了前三名
我们就可以知道A班非常的厉害
是全校的优秀班级
学习氛围非常好
回到股票
刚刚谈到的升学A班非常厉害
代表在股市中强势产业族群
这个族群的股票上涨的机会也非常的大
像是前阵子很热门的AI人工智慧的族群
其中的辉达公司在强势上涨的带动下让许多有关AI产业的公司也跟着上涨而我们可以在强势的产业当中找到前几名的股票这些都是属于强势的股票认真的你可能会想知道
那如何进一步提高投资获利的胜率呢
一样用升学班来做例子
当我们挑选出优秀的班级之后
如何再进一步挑选出这些优秀的学生呢
这时候呢
我们会依据自己的习惯来去做观察
像是有些人会看现在过去的成绩
来长期客观来判断
而有的人会看脸的面向好坏啊
有没有头顶高大啊
代表呢有大志向多智慧
那有的人呢
哪一个学生被大多数的老师
所关注跟重视
来去评估选择有潜力的学生
而这些大部分呢
都是我们可能会参考的依据
来帮助我们调选出更优秀的学生
好那我们再回到股票
刚刚我所提到的一成绩好坏
你可以把它想象成股票的基本面
也就是这一间公司的本值
目前这间公司一段时间的营收有多少
然后成长又有多少
二面向的好坏
你可以把它想象成股票的技术面
代表观察K棒形态的图形啊
走势啊
来去判断这张股票是否会上涨
三重视的程度
你可以把它想象成股票的筹码面
代表呢
目前有多少的有钱主力大户
用多少钱来买进这档股票
不管是基本面
技术面跟筹码面
都是我们选股的判断跟条件
当符合越多
我们就越有可能找到这些强势股
而我们的胜率就会越高
许多的新手同学都是只看到某一档股票脏了好多了
然后才进场去追
事后才知道原来这一支就是强势股
但这个时候都是晚人家一步甚至好几步进场之后当然非常危险大多时候直接会造成你的亏损而你知道吗在这个世界上真的是有方法可以在即将上涨的开始
找到这些潜力股
而我们学霸德老师
其中有一招高胜率的选股方法
就是利用技术面
筹码面跟基本面
三个面向去挑选股票
更精准的去挑选
即将要上涨的有潜力股票
老师也是靠这一招
在疫情的时候找到了强势股
做到百万以上的获利
而今天老师呢
有免费的教学
有兴趣的可以到我们的下方咨询栏
点选第一个连结
报名免费的线上教学
来了解老师高胜率的选股技巧
老师会分享他多年的13经验
高胜率的选股方式
可以帮助你扫走弯路
透过前男人的经验
来加速学习正确投资技巧
你不需要有金融的背景
也适合新手中手老手
如果你想要创造第二份收入
不想要自己耗费时间摸索的话
那直接跟有结果的人
拿经验最有效率
再來我有個問題要來問你
請問關於強勢股哪一個是錯誤的
1.具備抗跌的特性
2.有上漲的潛力
3.找到強勢股之後呢
不需要任何的判斷來決定進場跟出場
4.強勢股以後會有下跌轉弱的可能
把答案寫在留言處
這能夠幫助你內化今天的影片內容
答案發在底下的描述欄裡面
不要作弊
如果你有答錯的話
或是想要複習
可以把今天的影片反覆幫我們重複觀看
或是你有任何的投資問題
歡迎在底下留言
提问,最后学法祝福你在投资的道路上面
获利满满,带到财富自由
最后你现在,如果已经看到这边了
代表今天的影片内容对你也有所帮助
帮我们按赞跟订阅,是对我们
影片的支持,如果你想要收到我们的
芯片商家通知,一定要开启小铃铛
才不会错过哦,我是Wayder,我们下个影片见
拜拜